[Applause]
let june the 23rd go down
in our history as our independence day
the british people have made a very
clear decision to take a different path
no one really knows what the future is
going to look like
jack you're not allowed to face the
shocking defeat
of the remain campaign we've got our
country back
caused the largest collapse of any major
currency in the history of the modern
global financial system
you could literally watch the pound
falling off the edge of cliff
if the last time we saw falls of eight
percent
not sure we actually know people in the
city of london
were running their own private polling
to get information about the vote while
it's still happening
it was probably one of the most
lucrative nights for the hedge fund
industry that there had ever been
[Music]
my name's gavin finch i'm a journalist
at bloomberg news i have a financial
crime
i'm kim simpson i'm an investigations
editor
and writer my name is kit chalel i'm a
reporter with bloomberg and a writer for
businessweek
and we're the three reporters who broke
the brexit big short
the brexit night was a huge deal for
everyone in the country i watched
it on television the same same way most
people did at 10 pm
voting stopped the polling stations
closed all
of the networks all of the broadcasters
went immediately to their coverage
in or out it is too late to change your
mind now
so within the first minute they had
a concession from nigel farage who was
the global face of brexit
this statement as the polls close it's
been an extraordinary referendum
campaign this is nigel farage
turnout looks to be exceptionally high
and looks like remain
will edge it i remember being shocked
when i heard that just because it was
quite out of character for somebody
like him to concede before even the
results had been counted
later that evening nigel farage came out
again with a second concession speech
and this one was a bit more specific
than the first
and this one he said that romaine had
won
and that he had heard this from some
friends in the city who had run some
pretty big private polling
and that really shook me that was when i
really realized wait a minute
the pollsters secretly working with
hedge funds
and nigel had access to that information
uh
before any of the votes were even
announced
that was the moment when i realized
there's a lot
here for us to look into
first thing that i did was i created a
very detailed timeline
of everything that happened politically
everything that the pollsters were doing
and how the markets were reacting
we had to try to identify the polling
firms that were involved and the hedge
funds that they were working for
so we had these two giant haystacks that
we kind of had to go
searching for needles in we call this a
mosaic investigation you gather all the
pieces that you can
and you build a mosaic it's not a
perfect picture but it's a good picture
and and one that you can kind of see
what happened
so we set out to interview as many
of the polling company employees former
employees we started with so as not to
alert them to what we were doing
and people were genuinely scared about
the implications of talking to a
journalist about something like this
we basically wanted to know who the
buyers were of these polls
and who was conducting them and why
two polling firms that were notable in
all this and that we highlighted in the
story were yougov which is one of the
fastest growing polling companies in the
world
and a company called servation
hello and welcome to pop idol in the
early stages of both yougov and
survation part of their market legend
was built around the work
they did on uk talent competitions like
pop idol
and x factor
they were really the first to build uh
polling panels
large groups of people that were
available to them online that they could
tap with sort of the press of a button
what was interesting about those polls
is it was an early indicator that you
didn't need to know the outcome
of the actual competition you didn't
need to know who won x factor
all you needed to know was who was going
to vote for which candidate
on which particular week in x factor for
you to then
be able to make a market bet
[Applause]
for the brexit referendum the senior
members of the polling industry
told the press that it was not possible
to do a
a regular exit poll for this event their
normal methods their normal data
gathering simply wouldn't work
in this context what they didn't say was
they were secretly doing it for hedge
funds
at the same time who were trying to
profit on the day
from the ultimate inside information
which was an exit poll showing how
british people had voted
[Music]
hedge funds are among the most
sophisticated players in financial
markets
what they're looking for is an edge some
sort of insight that no one else has
that they can use to make their trading
profits and make money for their
investors
if the markets were deciding this
referendum they would have already
called it for
remain the pound is absolutely surging
on the markets the town kept going to
new highs all throughout the evening
if you're a hedge fund with access to
information
showing you that actually the opposite
is likely to happen
then you're in an incredibly good place
because you can play that market
all the way up to the top short selling
is essentially a bet
in a given direction the bet is that
something will fall in value
so the higher the pound is pushed up the
more money you make when it comes back
down the other side
hedge funds and banks were willing to
pay comparatively enormous sums
for the data that polling firms were
selling because it allowed them to trade
so profitably
100 million 160 million dollars 300
million dollars
in a single day when you're looking at
the definition of insider trading
insider trading is
when you have access to and trade on
non-public market-moving information in
this country
exit polling data is criminally defined
as non-public information
it is a crime to provide it to the
public or any section of the public
before the polls are closed polling
companies were streaming it all day long
to their secret hedge fund clients long
before the polls were closed
so that they could trade on how people
were voting
while they were still voting i hope and
pray
that my sense of this tonight is wrong
nigel farage does seem to think
that the referendum is lost the results
as they've been coming through this
evening
rather i think cast doubt very early
stage on mr farage's rather low key
approach to what's going on so on the
evening of the
the brexit vote after markets have
closed the concession speeches
which nigel gave certainly did drive
markets higher what we wanted to
understand was
why did he concede that night what
information did he have when he made
those concessions
what was going through his mind and
whether he had access to some of the
private polling
that we had identified that was being
done by hedge funds so we really had to
figure out a way to get
to try and get to the bottom of some of
this and we asked
nigel to come to lunch with us
so we met nigel farage at sweetings that
was on kit's suggestion
and it was a good one because it turns
out that nigel was the third generation
of his family
who had been eating at sweetings
it's kind of a strange venue it feels
like stepping back into the 1950s
they'd be running through the door with
him and he immediately had to go at the
spanish
host and waiter for being spanish i'd
never eaten oysters before
and nigel farage insisted that i try
oysters
about halfway through the meal you know
attention our attention certainly
changed
to um our story we started asking him
about his concession speeches
if we just try to call him up and ask
those questions he would have hung up
the phone
or if we knocked on a story he would
have shut the door but he felt i think
compelled at that point to to give us
full answers and
um and we got him he certainly confirmed
to us
that um in between you know at least the
beginning of the
the first concession and the second
concession he had spoken to
damien lane's low observation damian
linslow is the founder and the ceo of
servation
he built salvation's reputation in the
early days
by polling in a way that
drove ukip's results higher that
immediately brought him to the attention
of nigel farage and he became
nigel farage's pollster in ukip's
pollster and a very key political
advisor for nigel farage
nigel knew from his favorite pollster
leave had won before he gave at least
one of his
concessions that really pushed the
market in the wrong direction that night
so that was pretty critical for us to
find out on the night that he gave the
concessional speech
we do know there were others within ukip
um and within
the leave eu campaign who
were very curious as to why he was going
on air
saying that leave had lost
because they too had access to this
private polling data which showed that
leave had won the reasons he gave to us
that he made those concessions was
simply that
he had an attack of nerves essentially
when the moment came
he got jittery and nervous and lost
faith he described being in
a sort of black despair and a gloom
about what the outcome would be
and losing hope what his personal
dealings were were not sure of
but we're still looking this whole
process
was us building a very complicated
jigsaw from scratch
and it perhaps wasn't right until the
end of the reporting process
that we really saw the whole picture in
all its complexity
the fallout was massive i mean we were
really surprised that a story about
derivatives
essentially was like the third biggest
trending thing on twitter
and it didn't take long for um
uk lawmakers in both houses of
parliament
to start calling for official inquiries
into this
it matters to different people for
different reasons it matters if you're a
trader
because it matters if someone else has
an unfair advantage over you
it matters if you care that a handful of
people
can make huge sums of money by
betting on political events that shape
our future
and using information that would be
illegal for uri to look at
i think it matters if if politicians are
involved in this
and we should know more about it
you